All right. Let us begin. Let us
look. Turn down the music of Charles
ours. We'll come back to Charles,
but let us begin with her.
Uh, discussion of musical form,
continuing our discussion, musical form.
Last time we talked
really about three forms.
We talked about verse and Chorus in
Popular Music and we had wonderful
presentation by Frederick Evans and I
hope you came away with the following that
in dealing with verse and
chorus basically leak,
you have the same material you have to
say musical material coming back again
and again and again with the chorus,
we actually have the same text coming
back again and again and again.
But with the verses,
although the music is the same,
the texts keeps changing each time we
get new stroll fees are new versus of
tech. So keep that in mind.
Verse, Chorus, verse, Chorus.
Sometimes this can start with the course.
Sometimes there's a harmonic change in
here that we would call, uh, the bridge.
But essentially it's the repetition of
the same material over and over again in
terms of the music. But in terms of
the text, you get new texts each time.
For the verses.
We also talked about the
simplest of all of these musical
forms ternary form, right?
And that was simply this idea of
statement, contrast statement.
A be a very straightforward,
not too much. We need, uh,
do with that.
Today we're going to go on and
talk about theme and variations.
And with regard to all three of these,
I should say that all three
of these forms are very old.
I could go back into the Middle
Ages and get a response, sorry,
of the Middle Ages that is in a be a form.
I could go back into the
middle ages and pray,
bring up an early 15th
century English Carol.
That's inverse and chorus form.
I could go back into the Middle Ages and
find you instrumental pieces that are
in theme and variation form.
So these three are very old now.
The fourth one that we talked about,
Sonata Allegro form is an,
is adventitious,
is something constructed
in the 18th century,
adventitious to the 18th century.
So it was something put together in some
that measure by Joseph Haydn and then
passed on to his good friend
Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart. So eight.
So Sonata Allegro form,
this big complex musical form is a
little bit different than the other.
It's a lot younger.
It's a lot newer beginning with the
period of classical music, Mozart,
Haydn, and Beethoven. All right.
With that, by way of a, um,
uh, introduction, let's go
back to Sonata Allegro form.
We said that was the largest,
the most complex of these musical form.
Why are we dealing with this?
Well, next a week from Saturday,
we will go to this concert and we will
sit there and we will listen to pieces on
this concert.
The opening piece will be in Sonata,
allegro form it be by Mozart.
Then we will have a piece by Johan is
Brahms in theme and variation form.
Then we will have a symphony
by Beethoven in five movements.
It's an exception and we'll explain why
when we get to it in five movements. But,
uh,
within those movements,
we have a couple of instances
of Sonata Allegro form,
a couple of instances of theme and
variation form and one instance of ternary
form.
So all of these forms will be necessary.
We will have to understand how these forms
work in order for us to really engage
that particular particular concert.
For example,
you'll be asked to write a review of
that concert and I was thinking this
morning, well I kind of mediocre review
would say well in the middle of the first
movement of the Beethoven piece and we
once again we wouldn't call it a song in
the middle of the Beethoven a synth
first one was a Beethoven symphony.
Things seem to be disorganized.
What I'd like to hear there is,
well in the development section,
in the development section of the first
movement of the Beethoven Symphony,
uh,
it seemed disorganized because the
counterpoint was not clear because the
imitative entries of the parts
was not clearly articulated.
And that would be a much more specific
sort of response to the music and much
more educated if you will,
response to the music.
So that's where we're going with all
this to kind of sort of get you to think
about precisely where you are and
precisely what should be happening.
And then is it really happening the
way it should be? Yeah. As said,
so not allegro form is the most difficult
of these and it takes a little extra
time to get familiar with it.
We're going to be reviewing this
in section starting this evening.
And don't forget we have this model
of what Sonata Allegro Form Is.
It didn't want to put that up on
the board again, did that last time,
but you've got it on page
one 93 of your textbook.
If you weren't that complex
diagram one 93 of your textbook.
So get familiar with that and do once
again bring your books to section. Uh,
this time cause we'll need
him in section this time.
So we've got this complex
form and I've thought,
I've figured out over the years the,
the,
the way to sort of wrap your arms
around this or get into this,
understand this and it, it, it,
it involves the fact that music in the
classical period is what we would call
rhetorical music. It's doing something
at every moment. It is doing,
as I see it, one of four theme
things. It's presenting a theme.
So we'll have a,
what we call a thematic function.
It's moving from point a to point B.
Remember with the Beethoven,
that's the opening theme.
And then the second theme is [inaudible].
Those are both themes that stating
something that we can sing that we can
remember,
but they don't,
it has to get from point a to point B,
the more lyrical major.
So he writes a transition.
So the second functional type
here is transitional music.
We want to be able to differentiate
thematic music from transitional music.
Then there are passages
and in Sonata allegro form,
it's in the middle of the movement
that are exclusively developmental,
where you take the
material and play with it,
you can make it expand it
and change it that way.
You could shorten it as Beethoven
often doesn't work with just particular
motives. Uh, it tends
to sound very complex.
There's a lot going on in the development
section. It's the most polyphonic,
most contrapuntal counterpoint
polyphony sort of synonymous, uh,
the most complex in terms of the
counterpoint. And as we said before,
it tends to move around a lot because
they pass the, the composer's,
we'll pass through different
keys in the development section.
So we've got so far,
three of what we call the four functional
types or what I have called the four
functional type steam attic,
transitional, developmental,
and now we have to talk
about the last one,
which is the simplest in some ways
cadential where the composure,
we'll just throw on a lot of of heavy,
simple harmonic motion to slow
the music down psychologically,
not the tempo actually,
but psychologically sort of bring it
to a close so we can say a closing
functional type again to review thematic,
transitional,
developmental and cadential.
Those are our four functional types. It
will show up with any movement of Sonata.
Allegro form question
cadential that with a w it was that it
that it's Daniel, is that right? Yeah.
Yeah. How do you spell that? Oh,
well just take Kayden's C, a,
d e n s,
c e and turn it into cadential t I. A. L.
I don't know if my spell checker
kicks that word back or not,
but we use that term in music a lot.
You know,
this was a cadential gesture
and suggesting that we're
going to get into the end
of something. So it, I remember we
had cadence been the end of a phrase.
Well it's just the end of it and have
a section here. Any other questions?
That was a good question. All
right, so to get rolling with this,
let's listen to some music now.
Enough talk from me.
Let's get listened to some music and I'm
going to play for excerpts here mostly
here again for Mozart for excerpts and
you see if you can identify which of the
functional types is in play
here. Okay, Linda, here we go.
Okay, we're going to stop there.
Let's review just for a moment,
how do you tell these folks all types?
Well,
what are you looking for here
listening for? With thematic,
you want to be able to kind of singer or
you recognize it as something that you
could walk out of here.
Hammad so something that's that you can
sort of take with you. A transitional,
this idea of a little bit
unsettled in lots of motion.
Uh, cadential as I say, that's
probably the easiest because
bump, bump, bump, bump,
bump, bump, bump, bump, bom, Bom,
bom, bom, something like that.
Bringing it to an end and developmental
is going to be rather a complex,
lots of counterpoint and going on. So
let's go, let's go back to the beginning.
I messing up Linda here again,
but let's go back to oh seven there
and we'll start all over with this.
With that in mind,
okay?
Yeah.
Okay. So that's number one.
Here's extract number two.
Okay.
Yeah,
an expert number three.
Okay.
And number four.
All right, let's go back now.
Let's hear one, one more time,
and then we're gonna ask for a volunteer
to take a stab at which of the four
functional types you think this is okay.
Number one.
Okay.
Stop right there. So what brave
soul, we'll take this one on.
Uh,
sorry,
Carolyn, please. Transitional. Uh,
that is correct. Yes, that's correct.
Now what, what did you hear there?
And there's hard to play the whole
thing again, but what were you thinking?
What came, what, why did
you jump to that conclusion?
Wow.
Okay. At the end of it, it
did kind of slow down. You
had a sense of arrival there.
There was lots of motion, there was
lots of movement. Lots of movement,
and then at the end, a sense of arrival.
All right. We've arrived at a new,
and probably a theme is going to
come in at the, at that point.
So that is in fact a
transition. Let's listen to, uh,
once again to excerpt number
two here. If we could, Linda,
sorry,
because it's, it seems a
lot of, um, a lot of, uh,
um, we're not going to kind of in the
base and it's really the bleeding into the
descending melodic sequence of melody.
It's coming to a close
bump. Okay. I think the key
there is it's very monotonous.
You use the word monotonous.
It's very monotonous in a debate.
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, bom,
or something like that. As the
melody cascades down, I guess it,
but listening to the base there,
you can tell them that's just a
very monotonous harmonic pattern.
So harmonic patterns in
cadential passages here.
Cadential functional type tend to be,
as Frederick says, monotonous. Okay,
let's go on to number three now.
Stop
and Q. That one again. So
what do you think about,
about that name please? Roger.
Okay. Faraway. Roger. Thematic, right?
Can you sing it?
Play it again for Roger,
but really putting Roger on the spot here
this morning. But let's, let's see. Uh,
if you don't have to be,
I'll play it.
The candle.
Okay. So that's it. Okay. Right. Just
as I just played it. So, all right,
so that is a melody. Let's cue that
again. And just while we're at this,
notice what Mozart does with his
melody after giving it to us,
sort of does some very interesting,
I think so.
So let's have the beginning of that
same number three again, please.
So here's our lovely melody,
major or minor,
major sweet.
Sounds delightful.
Now watch what he does
here. Just drops. If though,
just the little twist in mind,
same melody,
which is lowering that
third degree of the scale.
Okay? So that's a good example of, um,
see Madec functional type here is
extract number four. What about this one?
And we'll, we'll just stop it there and
you can go onto to the next one. Well,
what about that one?
Yeah,
yeah.
Go for the obvious answer here.
It's going to be named please
later. What? I beg your pardon?
Developmental and why, what
did you will, uh, yeah,
because it's the only one that left,
et Cetera, et cetera. But, but did you,
could you,
uh,
tell us something that you heard there
that sort of backs that up or confirms
that it is developmental?
Yeah.
Many threads weaving it in
a t, t, t, t, t, t, t, t, t,
t, t, t, t,
all sort of simultaneously many
different ideas happening simultaneously.
Typical of the complexity
of the development section.
We've got some more on the tape here.
We're not going to go through to them
quite socially. Let's play one more. Uh,
it could be any one of the four.
Here's another one. Number five.
I think it's still on track.
Track three zero 37.
Okay. Take her, is there
a name please?
I should know this young lady
right in front of Thaddeus.
You had your hand up
first. Oh, Mary Pat. Okay.
It was transitional. Uh, and it just
the one hearing that's awfully good,
but you could hear it kind of
bill yet. T t t t t t t t t
t t t. T. T. T, t, t, t, t,
t, t, t, t, t,
and then it stopped as if it had
arrived at the end of the transition.
The musical journey was over. So that
was transitional. Here's another one.
[inaudible]
takers there.
Oh, thirtyish. Okay. Was
Developmental. Excellent.
Then I guess once again, lots
of things going on there. Uh,
probably developmental and
transitional may sound most similar.
They're probably the two that are most
difficult to differentiate thematic.
Yeah, you can kind of remember
that as a melody credential,
probably pretty straight forward. Um, uh,
so there's a tendency with two confused,
the transitional and the developmental.
It's just that there's
oftentimes a developmental,
a lot more counterpoint going on.
All right.
One last one here and
then we'll stop this.
[inaudible].
Okay.
Nobody's
driving that sucker into the ground
with it. Sort of the sledge hammer,
but cadential ending there.
Okay. So that should help you.
We get the sections this week we're
going to be playing pieces and sort of
having you track along where
we are in Sonata Allegro form.
Let's turn our attention now
unless they're questions.
Any questions about that?
If not, let's turn our attention
now to theme and variation.
We're moving on to theme
and variation form,
which we will also need for our
concerts a week from Saturday. Here.
What we have is not this sort of complex
organic mixture of many different
themes. First theme, second theme,
concluding theme and things like that.
We have one theme usually,
usually just one thing and we will get
that theme and then we will get that
theme again with something changed and
then we will get that material again with
something change.
And again with something changed.
So think of this as a kind of series
of boxcars on the railroad train or
something like that.
Units more or less the same size,
but each of those boxcars going to look
a little bit different as it goes by
because it might have a
little different logo on it,
a little bit of different
ornamental material on it.
All right, so we're going to,
uh, uh, let's see for time, maybe,
maybe I'll will not do the ivs.
We were going to pull it out.
Maybe we will have a little bit of
a theme demon variations. Again,
it goes all the way back to
the Middle Ages. Uh, and it,
they tend to be written on
the rather simple themes,
particularly patriotic themes. Maybe I
was thinking about this the other day,
maybe because patriotic
themes are pretty simple.
So the simpler the theme,
the more likely that theme is to be
come the basis of a set of theme and
variations.
Maybe it gives the composer
more freedom to pursue. Now,
I think I brought in some
variations of Beethoven on God.
Save the king. Yeah, here we go.
So here's Beethoven writing God,
save the king. And here it started.
Yeah.
All right, so very simple tune. And
then he writes a set of variations.
Here's variation one.
So there's that tune now in the late 19th,
early 20th century.
Yale's own Charles Ives and
he gives classes, let me know.
Oh Nay. 1898, something like that.
He used to be the organist and the
the first church, the green here.
So this is jails.
Most famous classical composer wrote
a set of variations on this same tune,
but they sound a little bit different
because it's closer to the modern period
and they're performed here on an organ.
So Charles Ives variations on America
[inaudible]
talk about a long reverberation time.
How long it took that organ sound,
the clear that church.
Um,
so that was written right here in new
haven by our own Charles Ives. But again,
the point is that it's a very
simple idea to rather simple tune.
Here's another simple
tune that Mozart used. Uh,
its original title was variations
on [inaudible] Mama. Oh,
let me tell you Mama. And
it's the, it's a story of a,
of a young woman who has gone to the
big city and unfortunately lost her
virginity.
But we know this tune not
with that French text,
that Mozart first learned it with,
but this way.
Okay.
Okay. So that, that's the tune.
But originally it was a kind of French
popular popular song going back into at
least the 18th century.
Uh,
how many different titles
can we give to this?
What do you know this ash?
Cool.
Twinkle, twinkle little
star. Anything else?
What bad ba black sheep didn't.
Sesame street used to use letters
with it. A, B, c, d. Dot. A, B,
c, d. And so, so it's gotten a
lot of traction over the years.
Uh,
and here's the melody
and here's the first variation.
Now my question to you,
is this with theme and variation,
the components or can keep the theme
more or less exactly as it is and change
the context around it or
he can change the theme.
So which does Mozart doing the first one?
Very,
oh
yeah.
Thoughts about that?
Is he changing the,
the theme or is it keeping the team
exactly the same and and changing stuff
around it? What do you think? Well,
what he's doing is changing the theme.
The theme would go
right at the beginning instead of I get,
so there's only really one note that's
that's that relates to the theme there
and then,
well no,
I get,
so he's sort of changing the theme by
making the notes go quicker and Warner
many around those notes.
So that's a variation one.
Now what variation too? Does he change
the theme or does it just changed the,
all the stuff around the theme
and so on.
So what's he doing there,
Caroline?
Changing what? I'm sorry.
Couldn't hear. Changing the
context. Changing the context.
The theme in the right hand
stays exactly the same. Uh,
okay.
Here is the next one.
What's that?
Well it goes with this.
So has he changed the theme?
Yeah,
he's changed the theme rather
considerably there. Indeed.
We wouldn't know that that had anything
to do with twinkle twinkle little star
unless we had had given to his
previously as we have the melody.
So we are hearing in our inner ear.
Yeah.
Ah, ah, ah,
ah,
ah.
So we know that's the basis of this and
if he wants to deviate from that we can
still say,
oh yeah,
that's related to that is getting rid of
the far away from the original because
we were sort of locked in
the original in our mind,
in our ear at that point.
Uh, here is, um, oh,
let's, yeah, let's skip that one.
We don't need it here. What happens?
What happens here?
Is the theme changed or is it still there?
Uh, and the context changed. And what
rhythmic device is Mozart using here?
So did he change the theme there?
Well,
basically no, except just a little
bit because he was doing what to it.
Okay.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump,
bomp using, take a patient.
So he was syncopating the theme,
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, bom,
that kind of, and he did one other
little fill up here, if you will,
in what we might call the
B section of the tune.
The tune originally went
and now it's going.
And then
so what's he done to the melody?
Anybody here that went
Oscar?
Yeah.
Yeah. He's filled in the notes
of a diatonic major scale.
The other nodes, the black key notes.
You're making it a chromatic scale season.
Enriched it a little bit by
means of chromaticism. All right,
let's go into another
variation by Mozart here.
What's the texture of this variation?
MMM.
So you think about the texture of that
homophonic monophonic or polyphonic.
Polyphonic yeah.
Was the imitative or non imitative?
Here's the beginning.
Okay.
Imitate.
Right.
So this is actually a kind of throwback
to the sound of Bach and this is what we
will be engaging when we come to the fume.
It's like Mozart trying to write, uh,
in a few goal way here
with lots of imitation.
And what happened to the
mode in this variation?
Okay.
Well as you're running it up as a scale,
but what kind of scale? Minor scale.
Okay. Um, and then oddly the final,
the final variation. A, what does he
do to the meter in this last variation?
What happens there?
We were going to king.
Ooh.
So what's he done to the meter?
Okay,
well let me strip away the bay.
He's changed it to football
by throwing in extra bar,
a filler in between each
of his basic Dupo beads.
Then we come to, uh, maybe, okay. Uh,
let me just cut to the chase here
at the end of this. He's coming in.
What's this? All the way to the end
now. What do we call this formally
about that with regard
to Sonata Allegro form,
it was one of the parts
that shows up also.
It's another leg reform has nothing
to do really with the theme here.
It is a good example of a, a Coda, right?
Just something thrown on at
the end to say this is the end.
What's he doing here? What
is this? How complex is this?
It's just
day major trial.
He's just automating a major triumph.
So it's a good more credential stuff.
Sort of very simple material at the end.
Okay. Our guest artist is here. I see
him at the back can show. Come on up.
We're going to do another piece for you
and we're going to talk about a little
bit about Kensho. Very interesting guy.
How many of you know Kensho Watanabe?
Seen Kensho around, uh,
who's seen Ken show?
In what context?
Oh,
he's in my biochemistry
class. All right. Yeah. Cool.
So that means he does hardcore sciences
and you must too. Good for you. You're,
you're better. Far better man
than I. Um, all right. So yeah,
hardcore sciences, um, uh,
anybody else know can show from
other contexts. Yeah. Atlanta,
he's in the YSL.
What does he do in the YSL?
You seem sitting all the way to the back.
No,
you seemed sitting all
the way up at the front.
He's the concert master
of the wire. So, uh,
anybody else know Ken
on a different context?
Any members of [inaudible] Lee
College here? Anybody from Berkeley?
Nobody from Berkeley. That's a statistical
improbability. Uh, but, uh, uh,
you're the conductor of the,
one of the conductors of the Berkeley
Chamber Orchestra, right? Yeah.
So he's a conductor to,
which is kind of astonishing because
he's not really not a very good musician.
He doesn't really know very much about
music. Can show what note is that.
Yeah. What note is this?
But no, it is this.
Yeah. So he has a very keen
sense of absolute pitch,
which, uh, it really helps you
out if you're a music legend.
He was to say as we will be,
we'll be talking more about this.
One person in 10,000 has this
particular guest gift statistically.
So He's a very impressive guy.
And he's also in the five
year m a a B a program,
right? Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, at the
end of four years here, in addition,
taking all these heavy
duty science classes, uh,
he's been across the street and you're
going to get an inmate in music at the
same time. I don't know. He was, he
was a couple of minutes late today.
And you said he hadn't gotten much sleep.
And I can sure as heck understand why.
Uh, all right, so we have, uh, a
Kensho. What are you up to this year?
Everybody can come see you,
um, on, uh, what would that be?
The 31st of the, of of October. Yeah.
Yes. So the, that you
don't want to miss, right?
And you kind of have to put that together
and maybe that's why you haven't been
getting much sleep. So you're
putting that together, uh, and tell,
and I know that you've
got a concert coming up,
and if for some reason,
God forbid we can't make it to our
concert on the 18th or makeup concert,
could very well be the one on the 19th.
Don't you have a concert on the 19th? Yes.
Yeah.
So if you want to hear Kensho conduct,
uh,
you could do that on the 19th of October.
All right,
so we've got a piece here and I
don't want to get too far behind. Uh,
it's a piece by Correlly.
It's based on, uh,
a melody and a base pattern
melody and a base pattern.
And, uh, we'll play through little
bits of it here and then, uh,
we're going to play the whole thing. Uh,
do we need to tune again when you think?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. We've tuned the four strings of
the violin. We'll play just a little bit.
We're going to take this
section by section, Jacob Peery.
He's going to point things out
as we go along a little bit.
Not the most gorgeous sound
I've ever heard. It's amazing.
But do you have any idea how long it takes
to produce a sound like that? I mean,
how many years of just sitting there?
When did you start playing the violin?
When I was almost three. Almost three.
So you were a late bloomer that,
uh,
and you probably so busy with things,
but when you were really
focusing exclusively on this,
how many hours a day would you practice?
And that was really focusing to
pilot three hours a day, Max for me.
I was saying what I'm saying,
if you go to conserve it,
it's because you got so many
other demands on your time.
Are you playing any solos
around here this year?
I should have asked that
question. A little recital.
Second smells. Okay. All right.
Well we'll keep our eye out for that. All
right. So that's the theme. Uh, and then,
um, on, uh, in variation to the piano
will play the, the down beat and, uh,
the violin plays off the beat.
I think for reasons of time,
we won't do that when though.
Kensho. Let's go to number three.
Where are we good to get a good
example of Staccato in the music,
sort of short pointed notes.
Okay. So we'll stop there. So when
you hear Ken show playing Staccato,
then you know that we are in variation.
Three variation,
uh, for uh, we've got, he's
playing 16th notes. Uh,
so it's going to go fairly fast
here I guess, or maybe not,
but he's got a lot too.
He's got a lot to do here in variation for
okay.
So he's really, uh, there's
going to be workout from me.
I hope I can keep up with this
lead today. Uh, all right then. Uh,
yes,
the one who sort of scares me is variation
five because then he plays the theme
and I have all of this fast
stuff underneath. Let's just
do a little bit of that.
Okay.
How'd that the air, the lovely,
lovely theme there. That will,
number six is sort of fun because the
interest here is in the base of the piano.
It's a good example of something we'll
be talking a lot about in our course
walking babies. Um, so it, it,
the notes are all for the most part
contiguous and they all come in the same,
no value. In this case, the eighth
notes, it'd be here's the beat and the,
and then he plays the melody against that.
Uh,
number seven,
we have the violin playing arpeggios.
We've talked about that.
So here's some Arpeggios in the violin.
Huh?
That's, that'll give
you a sense of that. Uh,
number eight is a tricky one for us
to keeping it together because of the
triplet patterns.
So let's do a little bit with that.
And then nine, we have a sort of an
interlude. It's like a transition.
10 we're not going to do
anything with right now. Uh,
the violin plays harmony while there's
a kind of fast pattern underneath 11.
There's a lot of, oh 11 is sort of my
favorite, but it's, it's a, it's a,
it's a tricky one because of the
syncopation between the two instruments.
So that's kind of a fun
one. Um, and let's see,
we need to tell them
also. Uh, I like number,
maybe it's number 13 is really my favorite
because I got a very simple theme to
play in. He has to work like
crazy. And toward the end of that,
he's playing triple stops. You know, uh,
it's not that the violin
just plays one line.
The violin can play two
notes at the same time.
It can play three notes at the same time.
And if you really rip across and shift
quickly or just move your boat quickly
across the strings, you can give
the impression of four pitches.
But they all four have to be in tune.
So you gotta have four fingers usually
in four different spots and that's hard
to do. You want to play it a triple
or quadruple stopped for him.
There's just to any old where,
yeah,
so when you hear those chords, if violin
playing court, oh, that's easy, you know,
on a piano or whatever it is,
that's easy on the piano.
That's hard on the string instruments
cause you've got to get four different
fingers in four different spots there.
Each of those notes have to be adjusted,
just fractionally, just right for
it to stay in tune. When he does it,
you think it's very simple, right? Easy
to do takes years to be able to do that.
Uh, questions before we launch
into this, any questions?
So we're going to do the whole
thing for you, and it'd be patient.
We're going to run over just a little
bit today, but believe me, the, uh,
particularly the end,
you'll like it.
So Ken Sho Watanabi playing theme and
variations on Carollee's tune and base La
Folia.
Yeah,
no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Wrong page up here. And I
was feeling sorry. Okay.
I think we need, okay. Now we are back
to the, I had the goal page. Okay.
You stood
on it. I'm very sorry.
We found it. Okay. We,
we had just have all these pages
and Igor rives sometimes. Sorry.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Great. Great. Me just to
be able to play with a guy.
Thank you so much. Thank you
so much. Beautiful. Beautiful.